being the acting returning officer
that's the election of a member of
Parliament's for the worsley and Eckles
south parliamentary constituency held on
the 8th of June 2017 give notice that
the number of votes recorded for each
candidate is as follows Kate
Clarkson Liberal Democrats 1087 Tom
Dylan Green Party 842 Barbara Mary Keely
Labour Party 26,000 and 46 Ian David
Lindley the Conservative Party
candidates 17,000 667 the number of
ballot papers rejected was as follows
once of the official mark 15 voting for
more than one candidate 26 writing all
mark by which the votes could be
identified zero unmarked or wholly void
from 70 76 the total number of ballot
papers rejected was 117 the total number
of votes cast was 40 5757
the total number of votes cast
represents 62% of the registered
electors the majority of eight thousand
three hundred and seventy-nine I hereby
declare that Barbara Mary Keely is
elected as Member of Parliament
without parliamentary constituency I
[Applause]
would like to thank the returning
officer the counting staff and the
election staff for dealing with the
challenges in the case of the election
staff of a snap general election not one
they had months to plan but a snap one I
would also like to thank the police I
know they have been working very much
beyond their normal working hours since
the terrible events in Manchester and
thank you for that work today on polling
day I want to make a special thank you
to all who worked on my campaign
particularly my team in walk done have
been working seven days a week
Emily Megan my wonderful agent Sarah
Hall elections are not one just in the
campaign's they are one in hard work and
helping year-round thousands of people
who have often got complex and difficult
issues I have been honored to be the MP
for Worsley since 2005 and forwardly
nettled south since 2010 and I am proud
that my constituents have put their
faith in me again to carry on
representing them I am proud to be a
Labour MP a party which stands for the
many not the few we fought a good
campaign we fought a brilliant campaign
on policies which people in this
constituency have valued given that I
have worked nationally on Social Care I
was very pleased that that issue came to
the fore in this campaign it rarely does
people have shown in the way that they
voted how much the issue of Social Care
matters as well as things like free
school meals school budgets and tuition
fees all vital we need an end to
austerity we need an end to the erosion
of our public services through cuts and
particularly the NHS can I say I think
we were all so proud of the job done by
sword Royal with the victims of the
terror attack they did a brilliant job
but we cannot
we cannot just rely on the goodwill of
nurses and doctors to provide that
excellent care to do all the extra that
we expect of them after an attack like
that
they deserve to be better paid and they
deserve to be better supported and our
other staff who provide amazing public
services they deserve to be better paid
and they deserve to be better supported
as do all the staff as I say I will
continue to work very hard for everyone
in the constituency with the the backing
I know of excellent Labour councillors
in suffered and an amazing team that I
have in both Walton and Westminster
thank you
[Applause]